The Joe Rogan experience,
does he didn't elaborate
any further than that?
I don't think so.
I think he just leaves it that,
but still man,
Sean connery gets away with that because
he's handsome and he's got that cool
accent.
But imagine somebody else saying that law.
Yeah.
It's just bad.
I mean ultimately Sean connery is just
hitting women from an old school era,
so it's kind of funny to hear them.
Yeah.
That's why.
Because of like jude law,
don't know why I'm saying jude law again,
but he has a proper accent.
Is a handsome guy.
If he wound up saying
that in an interview,
it would ruin his career.
Yeah,
absolutely ruined his career.
Like who's a famous movie star today?
Who's like a good example
like Ryan Reynolds,
I guess at the handsome guy.
I'm not sure that it's one of those.
Ryan Ryan's.
Imagine if Ryan seacrest said
that it would know he's gay.
People would know that.
Like,
I know what you're doing,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I don't think he's gay.
I think he's a workaholic.
Probably doesn't have time for sex.
Okay.
This guy,
Ryan Reynolds,
this handsome bastard.
If he said that,
if Ryan Reynolds said that sometimes
you need to smack a mount holy shit with
the backlash,
be extraordinary.
Salon Dot Com would dedicate months
and months of of front page articles.
Yeah,
but what about all the
sites defending him?
None.
There'll be a few of those
bugs in men's rights.
Sean Connery Fan clubs.
Few of those embarrassing men's rights
sites were the right things like,
oh,
come on.
Why is you went too far?
You fucks.
You ruined the whole argument.
The whole argument is divorced laws.
The whole argument,
the whole argument is how many
guys get fucked over financials?
So weird salon.com started
attacking patent Oswald.
You know,
it's not salon.com.
Okay.
It's a writer.
A writer decided that they were going
to pick a hot button topic that didn't
necessarily jive or make sense,
but they felt like because Patton Oswald
was making fun of someone else's racism
by showing like essentially
very similar to a Co.
Barriers get in trouble
for it except patton.
Oswald is a fucking like oBvious
comedian and obviously known as a pretty
sensitive aware guy,
like the idea that he would say
something racist just for the joke,
like he was,
they knew what he was doing and
they decided to go for it anyway,
and that's when he attacked them,
lit up and he should have,
he should have their gross.
Like there's something about their,
uh,
their articles too.
If you go to salon.com,
one of the things is almost every
article starts with a question,
you know,
is,
is this the time to reconsider the
argument of who's funnier men or women?
Question mark is this,
you know,
this is this.
What's wrong with the right question mark,
you know,
like this.
It's,
it's weird.
They're like opinion pieces
that represent this article.
It just is like,
it's,
it's amazingly this guess,
guess what chicken butt does.
Anti vegan shaming beginning in preschool.
Is that they're a salon articles?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Mr. Show patriarchal hedge
among in sketch show titles.
That's the man from nantucket anti
transgender subtext and classic lillard's.
So true.
It's so true.
Knock knock joke.
Not inclusive to the
homeless salon articles.
You dummies.
You fucked with the wrong guy.
Yeah,
you did.
Who lit them up?
She's right,
man.
I mean I get angry sometimes.
Like the other day they were
comparing tina fey to um,
to louis ck and like,
it's the age old argument.
Who's funnier?
Men or women?
Fuck you.
Here's what's funnier.
Funny people.
It's not men or women.
Stop.
Amy schumer's hilarious.
Louis ck layers and tina fey by
the way is in even a stand up.
Right?
Okay.
She's an actress.
She's funny.
She's funny on shows.
She's funny and in movies,
but she's not louis ck.
Lucy get writes his own shit.
Performed his own shit.
It's all his opinions on
the world to save that,
that there's some sort of
a debate who's funnier.
Her him is completely distorting what
the art form is in the first place.
It's completely distorting it.
Like you're just looking for a
fucking salacious article title.
That's all you're doing.
I used to think,
I thought,
I thought they were like,
it seems like they were much more
respected and now they've gone down this
spiral where everyone's just
rolling their eyes at it.
They'll run out of shit to talk about.
Well,
you know,
it's just ridiculous.
It gets to a certain.
It gets a certain time when
you're covering the same
stories over and over and
over and over and over and over.
This cancel.
Colbert cancel.
Cold beer.
One fucking joke is merited like seven
or eight headlines for articles from
them,
like in the debate,
why he needs to make it right.
Make it right.
Jesus fucking christ like,
what are you talking about?
Make a joke,
right?
What was his joke?
I mean it was so.
First of all,
he's a character.
He's a right wing,
ridiculous character that says dumb shit.
Tongue in cheek every fucking step of
the way it was it offensive to asian
people.
I'll,
I'll pull it up right now so we could
see what the fucking colbert controversy.
I'll,
I'll pull it up,
but people are asking like hash tagging.
Hashtagging canceled co bear
because of a fucking joke.
Okay,
here's the,
uh,
here's the in.
He's apparently responded to it,
but let's find out what,
how many visits,
how many people did
respond to that hashtag.
Oh,
I don't know,
but they're all gross.
I don't know how many
people wondering how big,
if it's an actual big,
now it's pretty mint is it?
You can scan through it
and it's not just canceled.
Cole bear,
there's like.
It's just like that.
It's like a place where all the outrage
people have gone to express they're
outrageous.
They're pissed about anything,
and they'll just hashtag page right now.
Here's,
here's what they said.
Okay.
It all began thursday evening when
the coal baer reports twitter account,
by the way,
which wasn't even him.
It wasn't even him that wrote that was
someone that handles the kobe or account.
It's not,
it's not.
StePhen colbert quoted a joke from
a segment on wednesday's episode,
so they quoted a joke from a segment.
SO they took it out of context
and that's where the outrage came.
Quoted a joke from a segment that aired
that marked Washington redskins owner
dan schneider for setting up a charity
to aid native americans in lieu of
changing the team's name,
the original bid,
cole bear said he was inspired
by schneider to start his
own charity called the
ching chong ding dong foundation for
sensitivity to orientals or whatever.
That's in response to a guy who runs
a team called the Washington redskins,
which is an anti native american
slur making a charity for,
for,
for native americans,
without changing the name.
like here's the whole
context to that joke.
I mean,
he's not saying that there should be
a ching chong ding dong foundation.
He's mocking the racism of a guy
whose team is called a racist name.
Donating without changing the name.
I mean it's so obvious,
but salon has had like seven
fucking articles about it.
Some supportive,
but some would say he
needs to make it right.
Maybe you just cannot put that string
of words together in any context ever.
but I mean,
whatever he said,
I think that's exactly
what they're saying.
You can't say change.
You can't say that.
That's the n word.
It's hilarious.
I mean to to,
to,
to try to censor content content that
much that you've taken things completely
out of context,
completely out of the meaning and context
is the reason why language exists in
the first place.
It's everything to be able to expand
past really simple things like eat fuck
shit.
you need context to to have a goddamn
language and communicate each other.
We have to recognize subtleties and
when you pretend they don't exist,
that's when you get assholes sanctimonious
fuckheads who get crazy about jokes
that you can get people dedicated days
and days of their life to something that
fucking that tracy morgan says
about stabbing his gay son.
They're crazy.
Everything is taken completely out of
context and everything is something that
really warrants cancellation you.
You'd be shamed.
You need to be removed.
This is over-sensitive fucking moron.
It's weird how what you're expressing
right now is you're offended.
They offend you.
That's what's interesting
is it's like they.
What they are doing is so
much more offensive in the
thing they are offended by
the way they're expressing themselves
is so vile and disgusting that it makes
whatever tracy morgan said
or patent oswald said,
or cole bear say,
just seem like seem so tiny
compared to what they are,
which is they're like embryonic fascists.
If you gave them power and
they grew out of control,
if that,
whoever's like running the show at salon,
matt,
whoever's running the cancel,
cole bear in somehow they took power.
Imagine what kind of world would be
living god if you they could decide what
gets on these comedy shows.
Satire shows what you can
and can't get away with.
How many transgenders
need to be represented?
How many fucking gay people
how many fucking straight white males
need to be made fun of along with straight
white females.
I mean,
is it going to be a a chart where
everything's graft and made sure it's
completely even across the board?
Let's not life,
man.
Maybe they'll find something new to be
pissed off about because that's really
what they love is being
pissed off about stuff.
Oh,
they'd where they'd realized
that they lost their love,
which is the problem.
It's,
it's when you say they,
it's writers.
It's writers that they're attracting.
It's not necessarily logical people.
It's not necessarily representative
of the organization itself,
their individual writers who produce
something and then somebody greenlights
set,
but at a certain point in time you're
doing more harm than good because you're
so easy to mock,
but if you're like super left wing when
you get that far out on a fucking limb
and you want to cancel coca cola,
bear about a really
obvious joke like that.
You're fucking up everything cause you're.
You're making yourself
look unbelievably silly.
Like I know you feel right and I know
that you have this righteous indignation
behind what you're doing and you feel
like the that people need to know.
You need to realize the
harm that your word say.
You need to realize that
there's humor and humor.
People get hurt,
oh,
hiding,
but you're a bigot.
Hiding behind the mask of a comedian,
people get hurt,
people get hurt from jokes,
and guess what?
If you get hurt from jokes,
you're supposed to get
hurt from those jokes.
If you can't make fun of
something about yourself,
that means that you haven't acknowledged
that something about yourself that may
or may not be hilarious,
and there's a big difference
between someone saying
something unbelievably cruel
and evil and someone's saying something
where they're poking at you and laughing
and obviously he was doing that.
Obviously he was poking at the Washington
redskins guy and laughing and to deny
that it's just.
It fucks up the whole argument.
It clouds the water was shitheads.
Yeah.
It's strange to see salon.com in some way,
like converging with
nancy grace in some way,
right?
Yeah.
Like they're meeting somehow.
Salon is like put itself in this tear.
whoever the writers are.
Ours put themselves in that
awful position where it's like,
oh shit,
I'm nancy.
Grace and I were like singing the
same song and it's not all that.
There's a lot of great articles on there.
I still go there because they
have a lot of great articles.
It's just sometimes
they just go out along.
That's why you need a good editor man,
because you let a few riders fucking
throw stuff out there and you do serious
damage to your website or magazine.
Like you can really fuck your shit up
where you could develop a reputation.
You develop a bad reputation,
like a reputation for being ridiculous.
Oswald is attacking you for fun.
if people are looking forward
to it and it rings true,
that's the problem is
true what he's saying.
Yeah.
He read those titles.
They're all.
Those are great mock salon.com titles.
They're great.
You know,
but look,
if you go to like I get an email from
them every day and there's some great
things like the thing with John Stewart
mocking cnn for its continued coverage,
they've got that.
They've got an interesting
thing on chris christie,
the governor to about
are not all bad at all.
You know?
Not all bad at all,
but a friend of mine
hate advice for awhile.
He's like,
fuck that magazine because.
Because one article that he was offended
by and they came up five years ago,
but I mean,
yeah,
you can't blame the whole organization
because one thing fucked up right.